depuis sa victoire éclatante il y a deux
semaines on ne parle que de lui à
Washington
et il sait y faire
ce jeune politicien d'Orlando n'a que 25
ans et en janvier prochain il entrera
officiellement à la Chambre des
Représentants
devenons ainsi le premier représentant
de la génération Z élue au Congrès
un congrès dont la moyenne d'âge est
d'environ 58 ans
il l'a mené sur les thèmes qui lui sont
chers les jeunes en politique
le massage
et bien sûr le contrôle des armes à feu
des armes qu'il ne connaît
malheureusement que trop bien
[Applaudissements]
mais qui est Maxwell Frost il est
d'abord et avant tout un musicien
un percussionniste de talent qui a
commencé très jeune
[Musique]
et qui a entretenu cet art se
perfectionnant années après année
son père Patrick
il est évidemment pour quelque chose
[Musique]
à tel point qu'il a même produit un
disque avec le premier groupe de Maxwell
de charters
de la famille né d'un père haïtien et
d'une mère originaire de Porto Rico il a
été donné en adoption dès sa naissance à
Patrick Frost et sa femme d'origine
cubaine
très jeune il l'a remporté des concours
de discours et son talent musical la
probablement aidé
c'est d'ailleurs à l'école de musique
d'Orlando qui l'a rencontré un de ses
amis les plus proches iron Garcia un
musicien de carrière qui n'est pas
surpris de voir son grand ami devenir
membre du Congrès
[Musique]
déjà un potentiel futur président des
États-Unis en tout cas il a un modèle
[Musique]
il fascine sur la scène politique et
attire déjà l'attention de Joe Biden qui
le voit un jour peut-être comme son égal
[Musique]
face à cette pression sur les épaules
pour son futur max wellfrost nous sert
une réponse de politicien
depuis sa victoire la vie de Maxwell
Frost a changé du tout au tout
tout comme celle de sa famille aussi
avec son style et sa musique qu'il
n'abandonnera jamais le Congrès devra
dorénavant composé avec Maxwell frast
pour les prochaines années